[Music]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
crazy
[Music]
and it's crazy that we always get that
freeze frame just right uh it's so great
thank you for high quality editing
yvonne get rid of oops not yvonne ivan i
already [ __ ] it up immediately that's
great made him a check um you know what
it's fine dude let's just pretend like
it didn't happen and go
um
another episode of congratulations and
we're loving it dude if you subscribe to
our patreon great patreon.com
if not we enjoy having you on youtube
and just listening on all platforms and
uh you know we're just gonna try and
fire on all
syllables um
yeah dude had a crazy had some crazy
dreams last night what i know i always
say this but what is it about well by
the way first of all let me apologize
for this [ __ ] superman
curl right here just absolutely [ __ ]
unreal
most men dream of that [ __ ] but me that
[ __ ] just pops out
it's like i'm in a it's like i'm in a
comic book dude but i'm not it's real
life
sorry superheroes sorry break your heart
superheroes your boy's got it in real
life and you don't exist
but um yeah dude had some crazy dreams
last night i shouldn't say last night
should say this morning i don't know
what it is about that and i say this a
lot but your boy you know
[ __ ] i i can sleep like when i sleep
i do that [ __ ] like i'm a sleep addict
that's what i do it like i cocked the
[ __ ] out and if it's a good one i get it
rolling right i'm in that rem i'm doing
that [ __ ] where i like [ __ ] i'm just
at the tippy top of the [ __ ] sleep
cycle but not waking up and then back
down into [ __ ] fairy tale land that's
where we're going up and down and almost
peeking out of that [ __ ]
tippy top of the rem cycle and then we
go back down it's like a roller coaster
dude and you know sometimes i have to
wake up to go pee pee but honestly
lately i haven't been waking up to go
pee so my body's agreeing with me all
right my mind and my body are one
together and uh when i'm doing my rem
cycles and when i'm when it's coming to
pee pee and honestly what more can you
ask for
so
um your boy you know look yeah of course
johnny sleeps a lot and johnny takes
naps a lot and that's fine
um but i do i can take a nap from like
six to [ __ ] 7 p.m forget it dude or
from even like 5
to 6 30 if i want to stretch it out a
little bit longer than an hour then your
boy's gonna nap right
and he wakes up with crazy cool you know
what i mean curls like that is right
that's what got me thinking about it but
so i had uh i slept until eight woke up
and didn't have to
go tt's and that's fine i didn't have to
go go piss and that's all good and um
and so i thought you know what dude i'm
actually going to
just put this fireplace on i have a
fireplace in my bedroom
sorry cold guys
sorry to break a heart cold guys
but i have a far place in the bedroom
and yeah it's electric but it doesn't
matter we won't [ __ ] tell anybody all
right we don't put logs in been the same
logs there for the past five years when
the house was built all right
i click the button i wake up i walk up i
click the button fireplace goes
it always is like
for way too long right the fire's
already started and
for way too long go back to sleep
anger's rising because the sound's not
and now i'm not even it's not even the
sound that's keeping me up it's the
anger that's keeping me up that the
sounds are going
i'm like when does this stop all right
must have stopped do you know why johnny
dreams a lot okay i went back down into
my [ __ ] rem and i immediately i don't
know what it is about after 8 a.m but if
your boy goes back to sleep after 8 00
a.m
if he makes a deal with his body and
says you know what we're gonna take the
extra lap
in [ __ ]
dreamland
he scoops way under did you know there's
another level
did you know there's another level dude
did you know that there's another level
dude i must have been sleeping so hard i
must have been in whatever the earth's
core is in dreamland
bro i was down there i swear to god when
i was down there i saw a [ __ ] um
what's his name and eric brockovich
what's his name [ __ ] aaron
eckhart i must have saw aaron heckhart
at one of those [ __ ] things where
he's trying to get to the center of the
earth what's that movie called the core
bad movie um
and you know it's a bad movie because
aaron eckhart's the lead if in heck is
the lead it's a bad movie sorry said it
but we tell the truth here okay
i'm the truth i speak the truth dude
if aaron eckhart is the lead in it
terrible movie if aaron eckhart is the
second lead in him great [ __ ] movie
sully
it's a great movie tom hanks is the lead
aaron eckhart is the second lead great
[ __ ] movie erin brockovich great
[ __ ] movie julia roberts is the lead
[ __ ] airnet card is the second one
if you want a movie to bang
and ride like a roller coaster
put aaron eckhart in it
only build second if you put him in the
lead battlefield los angeles the core
[ __ ] other movies that i don't know
and the reason why i don't know them is
because they weren't hits and that's my
point all right box office disaster
aaron eckhart at number one box office
disaster aaron eckhart at number two
critical acclaimed winning oscars not
him though but the movie okay now
i'm in the core i passed aaron eckhart
i'm so low i'm dreaming right i got a
shovel i'm trying to get further i don't
know what it is about that after 8 a.m
sleepings that just puts me the [ __ ] out
like i was drugged and i thought it was
when i went to zanny island but it's not
i don't go to zany island i haven't been
a [ __ ] zany island in about a month
or month and a half
and i slept after 8 p.m and i killed it
dude i had weird dreams dreams of exes
in my past having meetings with them for
some [ __ ] reason serious meetings
where we were talking about real world
issues and then i had another dream that
thought you know it was like nothing but
it was like i was in
an auditorium
and people were playing baseball people
don't play baseball in auditoriums okay
but it didn't seem weird that it was a
dream it just seemed like it was the
thing to do now in this world we were
below the earth's core of dreamland okay
that's where we were
and we were listening in that song
car wash that's what it is i learned
that since last week i haven't get rid
of told me that
it's the beginning of the song car wash
and you never really know what baseball
games because they don't really [ __ ]
start the part where it's like we're at
the camash
they just get to the bar
boom and then they go and now batting
jeff kent
hensley mulins
john allrude
david cohen
fred
mcgriff ken kamenetti
wade boggs
kevin ellster
howard johnson
don mattingly
dwight goodin
dave parker
jose conseco
barry bonds
mark maguire
bobby bonilla
andy that's it that's it that's all i
had i got more but that's all i could do
with the [ __ ] with the you know what
i mean and uh they don't play none of
them play anymore bobby bonilla still
gets paid because he made a [ __ ]
great contract when he was back in the
mets in like 1990 or whatever but anyway
dude um
so i'm doing that and everyone chants
[Music]
and as it went
everyone would go rob he has bad clothes
don't know why dreams are [ __ ] weird
and that's all i want to say about it
[Music]
who's rob
whoops
forgot we left it in there twice who the
[ __ ] is rob dude
who's rob i dreamt it they say dreams
don't last longer than three minutes
i'm skeptical on that
i'm skeptical on that because we seem
like we were chanting that rob he has
bad clothes
[Laughter]
a long time in that auditorium dude
to the beginning of carl
rob he has bad clothes that's what we
were chanting and i don't know who rob
is but it's you know it's all good dude
and sometimes you just dream [ __ ]
sometimes you dream you have really
great meetings with your ex's that are
therapeutic and you're trying to solve
world issues and emotional [ __ ] and
sometimes you just dream about a
fictitious guy named rod rob and how he
has bad clothes in an auditorium where
you're playing baseball and that's it
and that's all i want to say
doesn't really seem like there's any
like dreams in the middle there where it
kind of makes sense but not really it
seems like it's either [ __ ] makes so
much sense or zero sense right
um
wow
so robbie has bad clothes and um and
that's honestly that that's all that's
honestly all i want to talk about but i
went down to [ __ ] the earth core of
dreamland man i really really did i
really did
um
speaking of the [ __ ]
the the absolute cool superhero hair i
got dude
yay they did it yeah
yeah
they did it yeah
yeah they did it they made [ __ ]
superman gay yeah that means
yeah they probably did the midsummer
night but it's not clark kent so does it
count no
it doesn't does it
everyone's like yeah for representation
yeah funny representations make clark
gay
who's [ __ ] john kent dude
the [ __ ] is john kent
john kent coming in all like
you know saving the day but not really
saving the day thinking he's saving the
day but not really saving the day dude
right
in my head dude clark's in the closet
period i don't give a [ __ ] i know he
loves lois lane i know he you know he
i know he's a power [ __ ] right because
he's superman but john kent and he's you
know
and he's gay and people think it's
amazing and that's like why are you
ruining superman they're not they're not
dude they're not ruining superman it's
all [ __ ] fictitious all of it people
say this is what the liberals want who
gives a [ __ ] let him have it you know i
get it how people are like how are my
kids supposed to read this i don't know
man
you figure that out
i don't care so much you know when i
first see a [ __ ] article like that i
got it i gotta i gotta admit i i go like
this what the [ __ ]
what a weird world who cares this much
but then i get okay people do care this
much so fine dude i don't give a [ __ ]
honestly i think every single
character ever
should be gay i think everyone should be
gay i don't just think john can and i
don't think i think clark kent should be
gay i don't know who the [ __ ] john ken
is by the way i don't know who it is
they tried to marry both sides and they
were like oh let's put you know maybe
he's another kent but also he's he's gay
but it's not clark kent because so they
can still have their clark kent right
the toxic boys could have the clark kent
but then also the gay boys they can have
the [ __ ] the what crowd they could
have john
it's so funny too it's like such a
[ __ ] it's like the the off-brand [ __ ]
right like clark kent is still gonna be
having sex with lois but
it's like it's like when you go in a
[ __ ] um
like there's vons out here on the west
coast and everyone goes to vaughn's and
then the people who can't afford it they
go to a place called john's with the
same font it's real dude people in la
know what i'm talking about but it's
real
in the worst parts of town there's
john's rhymes with vaughn's try a little
harder maybe it's [ __ ] john kent uh
john john kent maybe
maybe john kents maybe john maybe that's
what john's is he's the off-brand
version of vons and he's also the
off-brand version of superman and he's
got i haven't seen the comics here maybe
he runs a [ __ ] a popular food chain a
popular grocery store chain in the
you know in the inner cities i don't
know i don't know
but i do know if he's doing that he's
also stroking dudes off and kissing him
and [ __ ] because he's gay and that's
fine dude and that's fine
we have nothing against john kent
i want to meet him but i just think make
all of the characters gay everyone's gay
period also in tv not just comics
everyone should also have gay
relationships in like i'm talking about
lauren order that guy chris maloney
should come in and be like hey what's up
whoa nice you want to go out for a
coffee partner and then bust some cases
and then come back home to that dude and
just kind of cuddle him you know it's
over the pants [ __ ] because we're also
on whatever it's on nbc but dude
chris maloney
make him gay [ __ ] put purple hair on him
make him gay as [ __ ] at night right
that's it
whatever the [ __ ] thing is like uh
you know
happy days fonzie there's also gonzi and
he's gay as [ __ ] and he's got a purple
leather jacket dude
right
why not every why not who gives a [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ]
who do you care oh how am i supposed to
have my kids read this [ __ ] bro you'll
figure it out you had the kids
make your own comic books draw pictures
for your kids if you're so anti-gay go
ahead do that yeah and he's got a
[ __ ] and he's straight as [ __ ] dude
this guy's a fireman and he has sex with
so many women's man [ __ ] that he's not
gay at all
read that son
[ __ ] john kent
or just make your own super villain and
make him try to kill john kent how about
that
if you don't like john ken enough go
learn art airbrush it all together and
make a [ __ ] villain john kent who are
you i'm the john kent annihilator you
could make that character
it won't be in their comics but it could
be in yours
i guarantee you'd have a [ __ ] dude
and you know people are talking oh you
know crystalia he got [ __ ] red pilled
you know oh you're still a liberal cuck
but even though you know we had your
back and you or or some people you got
red pill [ __ ] this blue pill red pill
[ __ ] [ __ ] it all dude i don't do
pills unless it's zany island dude
i'm not red pill blue pill man [ __ ] all
this
everything in the world is so divisive
relax i'm talking about the purple pill
how about that take the red pill little
bit of the blue pill put it in together
and make a nice purple drink out of it
how about that
drink a purple drink
john kent he's around
gay superman cool as [ __ ]
that's it
you know everyone's so divisive about
everything
and it's like i'm pissed off because
[ __ ] it's like what can when can we
be pissed off about the real [ __ ]
bluetooth isn't ready for cars yet
it's not ready
for cars yet
every car i ever go in i link my
bluetooth to the car
i [ __ ] i try to do a voice note hey
i'll be right there
playback
i'll be right there no i said hey i'll
you gotta wait four seconds to do the
voice note for the [ __ ] bluetooth
shits
make bluetooth start recording on the
car immediately enough for this [ __ ]
oh look it's sarah hey what's up how's
it going hello hello hello and then
sarah hey hello are you do i ha do you
have can i hear can you hear me yeah
what what what's going on sorry it's
[ __ ] audi it's actually audi
[Laughter]
it's not ready they made bluetooth for
something that's not ready and they
still [ __ ] sell it
no i remember when louis ck said the
thing about being 30 000 feet in the air
and you and you can talk to anybody in
the world and you should be happy about
that so what if the [ __ ] [ __ ] doesn't
work no i disagree
i disagree only put the [ __ ] out when it
works
otherwise it ain't ready
yeah i ain't ready for this one that's
what the rappers are talking about when
the bluetooth doesn't work on the car
yeah they ready for this one
audi an iphone they don't connect
what's up with bentley even a bentley
yeah
even the [ __ ]
mercedes-benz
um
rob he has bad clothes bro
but dude it's just [ __ ] ridiculous
you can't take any issue
and it's not divisive but i don't want
to get too serious
but we can't talk about the real issues
like bluetooth are ready for i want an
npr this is my [ __ ] pr i want an npr
why doesn't bluetooth
you know the reason why bluetooth
doesn't work does [ __ ] [ __ ] ass npr
voices
the reason why bluetooth doesn't work
with cars is because they might sync
them and back in the air conditioning
when it came out and people would flock
to the movie theaters because it was
less expensive not necessarily because
they liked the movie but it was cheaper
than keeping their house cool
they always got that fake
[ __ ] ass laughing that they do god dude
these the radio person even radio radio
personalities were the ogs of that [ __ ]
they'd be like all right yeah we're
coming back from that side what are you
laughing at what just happened dude what
just happened in the studio
share it with us
your energy isn't affecting isn't
infecting me
unless you're sharing the experience
when i come on this podcast do i come
talk about boring [ __ ] and [ __ ] be
just be laughing about the thing that
all happened before the podcast no i
share my week with you so hey dj let me
know what you're laughing at all right
we got another pair of tickets to give
away oh my god here we go we got some
tickets we're going to give them away
we're going to give away erica bardu box
seats okay
what are you
[ __ ] laughing about
share with the class otherwise i turn
that [ __ ] right off every dj does all
right man all right yeah
are you getting tickled dj guy
hey dj laughs a lot play the music or
share the funny stuff
you're just laughing at hi how you doing
how's the weather
what's going on
tell us the [ __ ]
give us
the scoop
and that's all i have to say about that
[ __ ] dude
this is every dj right now every dj when
the music ends hell yes
and what are you laughing at dude at
least we saw beforehand when [ __ ]
jeff bezos was i don't even know
remember at this point but anyway dude
this is how they come back from [ __ ]
uh this is how they come come back from
uh right here they go
haha okay all right i got two tickets
we're gonna give away phil collins is
back in
india in a
concert
wow
we can't get to the real [ __ ] npr do
some [ __ ] about bluetooth anyway dude i
got you know i trailed off johnny trails
a lot and he does dude i do i trail i
trail off but that's what we do it's
tangents i should have named this
podcast tangents
venom is the number one movie in the
[ __ ] world venom venom two
i want so badly for one of these sequels
sequels to be called whatever it is
venom two
t-o-o so badly venom two venom also like
this is also venom the movie that you
just saw because guess what it's the
same as the last one venom two
they got woody harrelson just straight
up giving up and he's lauded man
sure i'll [ __ ] that man
you won woody you won woody
you
won
woody
i used to tell myself that [ __ ]
every night a few years ago
meant something different but dude i
it's like
do you see him on the poster on the
venom poster hopefully we can find the
right one and put it right here but dude
you've got tom hardy he's like i've been
in this movie before just doing it like
this
half of the venom face the other half is
woody harrelson making for real this
face
put it next to mine
that's what he looks like the other half
of the venom face hey woody harrelson
you're taking the piss congratulations
you're now my favorite actor that's it
it was nicholas cage it was counter
reeves
congratulations woody you're in my top
three now and that's that liam neeson
you're number four cause woody harrelson
took the top spot with the [ __ ] whole
half of the billboard just doing it like
this
unbelievable dude i got it the movie
made eight three billions and billions
of dollars
venom two came out and it made billions
upon billions of dollars if you were to
zoom in and see billions and billions of
the very dollars that you spent to go
see the movie
um
so yeah if anybody saw that that movie
venom honestly go [ __ ] yourself um you
know it's i realize that they're just
[ __ ] these movies these marvel movies
they're for kids dude adults are like
they're for kids and guys who push up
their glasses that say well actually you
know i just wanted to you know i know
it's funny but that's what they say
that's what they lead stuff with no you
know yeah sure i understand why you're
laughing but actually the point of it is
that's what those guys say right they
walk out of [ __ ] nine times out of
ten you walk out of a
if you just stand outside of a star wars
or a marvel movie or some [ __ ] like that
you get you get nine people out of ten
people opening day you know it trails
off a little later but opening day the
guys that are walking out are saying a
version of this no and i know it was
funny but actually the point of it was
that's what they're saying if you listen
close enough
okay
it just makes me laugh that people get
all bent out of shape when in that when
actual when in actuality that was his
essence from the from from issue number
46 when he first popped on the theme
in thor
um
so yeah dude it's just you know they're
they're for kids dude
right um
a guy came up to me the other day uh in
uh
i was at coffee bean you know doing what
i do just relax and having my eyes to
americano [ __ ] some people think it
goes against relaxing because i'm
caffeinating myself but that's how i get
to base levels so where i can just chill
all right
now i got the [ __ ] nice americano i
get it dry cloudy she [ __ ] serves me
up nice and as a matter of fact she said
can you shout me out on your podcast and
i said sure claudia and i forgot for
about two months until now so hi claudia
she's a beautiful lady and she's so nice
and she gives me my coffee the way i get
it i show up and i say hey
can i have it and she says you want your
dry ice americano and i go like this yup
also known as four shots
over ice and we have a laugh dude cloudy
and i we laugh
right
and so i get it and she says here you go
and i'm like wow that was quick and
she's like i know what you want dude
she's great look we have a good time
okay four shots over ice i'm drinking it
i'm sitting there i just sit down for a
little bit i want to get back home and
play with my son i'm hanging out though
i'm having a good time checking my phone
all of a sudden two hasidic jews walk up
to me now
i think here we go
right who knows
who knows all i know is
i don't deal with hasidic jews a lot
that's it so this is gonna go a certain
way and i have no idea what's going to
happen
i welcome the i welcome it i welcome it
they walk up to me two of them and they
say
hey and i say hey now i'm always
skeptical when somebody comes up to me
okay you have to understand a lot of
people know who i am a lot of people
like me a lot of people don't like me a
lot of people just want to annoy me a
lot of people don't know they're being
annoying a lot of people are very
friendly i get all sorts of the you know
i get the spectrum
back and forth right
so these two hasidic jews come up to me
and they say
hey
are you jewish by any chance
and it's one of those things where it's
like
i have to pick
the correct thing to say
next
that makes this the shortest exchange
possible right but the trick is you
never know what that is
right when people walk up to you and
they say are you a registered voter you
go uh oh
are they trying to get me to register to
vote or do they need me to be a
registered voter
so they can bother me longer right okay
so you're like
okay well i am registered to vote but
you're trying to study the person like
you're sherlock like trying to [ __ ]
move in on their cufflinks well they
have expensive cupcakes they might be
this and that maybe you don't know you
just guess you fire it away sometimes
you lie you're like no i'm not a
registered voter they're like good
because we're just getting registered
we're like [ __ ] i was lying and i got
you're like i was lying right but you
don't want to do so
most of the time i just bank on the
truth okay
i just go with the truth because then
this way i'm not in the wrong and i can
say not interested took me 40 years to
realize that that's what i had to do and
that was what was best
so these two hasidic jews remember this
is where we were hey by any chance are
you jewish
and i like this said
no
hoping for the best and they go like
this
all right
never mind thanks
[Music]
we won
i don't want to say i won against the
hasidic jews that sounds very
anti-semitic i want to say i won
the game
with the hasidic juice so
that's it i just don't want to talk to
anybody for too long right
uh but it was nice you know um
and i think honestly i'm gonna look into
the religion
i'm gonna be hasidic well imagine if i
was an acidic jew right and i just
[ __ ] started doing the podcast and my
and i just had like tendrils and [ __ ]
and big top hats i don't really know
what they wear but um
anyway that's what happened to me
and uh that's it
it's you know the [ __ ]
i do over i mean dude i know this is
like the reason why you guys listen to
this podcast but man i [ __ ] think and
i analyze everything as it is so thank
god i have a [ __ ] thing
about
uh
thank god i have a [ __ ] an outlet to
just talk about i can't believe hundreds
of thousands of you listen to this [ __ ]
um but it is what it is and i really
appreciate you guys and i love you for
it man
um but i overanalyzed [ __ ] everything
man i was watching you know what
actually you know what dude actually i
want to get your [ __ ] take on this
[ __ ] man i really do we're all friends
you're listening to me in your car your
cubicle or you got me in your [ __ ]
earphones when you're working out dude
this is [ __ ] so kristin and i are in
a situation where we'll get into a
discussion sometimes
albeit heated
she'll say something
and i'll get upset that she said
something because i get upset about many
many things
and then i'll
carry on that conversation with that
hotness in my body because of the fact
that she said this certain thing
and then after
the middle of the conversation i'll go
back to that thing she said and i'll say
well it's because of how you said this
and then she'll say
i didn't say that
so
what happened
who's right
i'll tell you who's right
someone
i think it's me
here's the problem she thinks it's her
here's the problem though
i'm sure it went down the way i thought
but here's the added problem
she's sure it went down the way she
thought
someone's right someone's wrong right
there's that whole thing where you'll be
in couples therapy and they'll be like
well what's true in your reality isn't
necessarily what she experienced and i'm
just like
but their words
and she said them
and then therapists are like but it's
not about the words and i'm just like
swallowing that because i know secretly
when i get to heaven god will be like
actually
it was about the words
off to hell
and um
so that's been happening it's been
happening lately and i don't know how to
do it you know we talked to our [ __ ]
therapist about it and you know we love
the [ __ ] out of each other and we always
come out the other end laughing and
being nice to each other but in that
moment of hotness and i'm just saying
this to you guys because i want to share
it with you because i want you to know
that you're not the only one okay i know
sometimes relationships get tough and
you guys bicker about dumb [ __ ] but the
common ground is the love right or the
like or whatever the [ __ ] you have you
know red pill blue pill no mix them
together it's that purple drink right
so that's what you're both trying to
experience together
now
we were at this
italian restaurant chain maria's kitchen
if you are a die-hard fan of this
podcast you know
about my history with maria's italian
kitchen i used to get it all the time
delivered they would [ __ ] it up 80 of
the time your boy got pissed did they
always [ __ ] it up yes 80 of the time yes
does that mean always in my book yes was
it okay it was in the grand theme scheme
of things but was it okay for my palette
that night no okay they'd either forget
the chicken or the cheese or the
linguine would be penne whatever it was
did i get pissed yes they didn't
necessarily bring me the right pasta but
boy did they bring me
annoyance all right so i'm at marie's
italian kitchen i vowed never to go
there again but then i realized i could
kind of change that when it was right in
the vicinity and i could change that too
i'm never going there again i'm never
going to order from there again so i
went and i took my son it took calvin we
took our friend
it was my our friend calvin and kristen
okay
and the lady comes to take her order and
she says hi fella to me no kidding to
calvin and she says hi fella how are you
and calvin's just like saying all this
[ __ ] really cute and kristen is like you
know what um i'll get uh
fettuccine with pink sauce
and she says sounds great
and i thought well that sounds good pink
sauce is the thing i usually get from
maria's italian kitchen [ __ ] a decade
ago so i say
you know what
i'll get linguine with a pink sauce
because i'm not really a fan of
fettuccine
i love linguine in fact it's my favorite
pasta i love the way it holds the sauce
penne
that's my brother's favorite but
honestly that's for suckers i don't need
no [ __ ] fat pasta in my mouth i want
that long stringy [ __ ] that lets the
sauce just [ __ ] drip down right it
catches them it plays the way the
[ __ ] sauce plays with that pasta and
how it dances beyond your tongue it's
beautiful right the marriage of the
pasta and the sauce that's that purple
drink for me
linguine into pink sauce
so she says you know what now this is
what
the lady says
you know what
we don't really have linguine we have
more of a spaghetti and then fettuccine
that's what she said
all right
so i said oh okay well give me the
spaghetti one then
and she said great
leaves comes back with the food
puts down the fettuccine yum pink sauce
looks great fettuccine not what i would
have ordered but i also from the looks
of it
i like the way it's playing with the
sauce
seems like a good marriage to me
then she drops mine down
and it's spaghetti with pink sauce okay
now
she drops it down i
fuel
inside nobody sees it she walks away
nobody knows
best
but nobody knows
so i say
to kristen well this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
and she says what and i said
well
she brought me spaghetti and i wanted
linguine
she should have just told me that she
didn't have linguine
and kristen says
she did
and i say
i had a feeling that you were going to
say that
but in so so what i did is i cataloged
the [ __ ] in my brain when it happened
and that isn't what she said she said we
don't really have linguine we have more
of a spaghetti and then fettuccine and
she said yeah that's what that means
they don't have linguine
now i'm pissed anger it's rising okay
trying to quell it trying to do my
breathing exercises i've learned from
therapy but it's rising it's breaking
through it and i say
beyond gritted teeth to kristen
she led me to believe
there was an in-between noodle
she led me to believe there was an
in-between noodle that they had
hey
if you don't have linguine
say
one thing
we don't have linguine
so then i say what do you have you don't
have more of a spaghetti and then
fettuccine you have spaghetti and
fettuccine
now i'm trying to [ __ ] tell this to
kristin and she's like
you know what it's not always and now
it's hot because we've already had this
conversation before
that's not what she said that's not what
you said that's not what he said that's
not what they said that's not what i
said
all we have are the words i'm gonna get
up there to st peter and he's gonna be
like
you know you were wrong i don't know
what the [ __ ] dude
unbelievable dude don't lead me to
believe there was an in-between style
noodle that like hasn't even come out
yet
like some new [ __ ] that like [ __ ]
apple made that like it's like oh whoa
there's a new one in between spaghetti
and linguine
yeah i want it and then it comes and
it's just a [ __ ] iphone 8 again i
don't [ __ ] know
does update work out or not dude does
bluetooth work in the car if the [ __ ]
doesn't work don't say it's gonna don't
color it a certain way so i'll be happy
because when it comes i won't be happy
dude
but whatever dude i'm working on my
anger
speaking of [ __ ] i was talking i was
at the coffee bean the tea leaf dude oh
my god what a debacle you ever have just
something that happens that's just so
normal
and so boring but if you actually
realize afterwards
how
like do you ever stop and think about
how actual
actually
like
stressed you are in the day right do you
ever feel your tension
i mean a lot of you do that's why the
calm app is so [ __ ] successful they
got lebron on the side of a building
just like calm with the side of his head
for some reason it's so so side of the
head to just have a [ __ ] meditation
app you know
it's so side of the head it's less
intrusive you'd never have a [ __ ] guy
just like
calm and just staring you in the eyes
they took one shot of that and they were
like lebron turn your head and he just
did that and they were like calm like it
was the drake album or some [ __ ]
anyway it's like rain falling or some
[ __ ] and some guy i'll tell the story
way too slowly
i can't listen to that [ __ ] when i'm
going to bed kristin tried to do it a
little bit and the guy was telling the
story so slow i'd fall asleep in between
sentences and then he'd wake me up with
a new sentence
so [ __ ] annoying dude
talk faster dude everyone does [ __ ]
completely [ __ ] wrong man
[Laughter]
you guys [ __ ] like
and the clouds parted
and that was and you're waking oh oh you
want me to wake up
say and the clouds parted and that was
when say that so i could fall asleep
during the day
i fall asleep over the [ __ ] color
girl i'll do i'll watch drumline and
fall asleep over i [ __ ] fall asleep
over this calm app
[ __ ] what's his name
oh marion on the side of the thing
drumline who was it not o marion [ __ ]
the guy on america's got talent side of
the face drumline
nick cannon
oh marion
how much was his name mario but he was
like i need to make him more fancy i got
an o and an n where should i put it and
then his friend was like the ends
um
oh [ __ ]
that's like if my name was to crystal um
so
oh wow dude so i'm losing my mind so
[Laughter]
to crystal um so i'm at the so i'm i'm
you ever realize how stressful the
situation is i can't believe i got back
on this tangent
off of the tangent out of that you want
to close that door but i can't believe
it so so we're watching so so we're
watching just saying things we're not
watching anything so you ever realize
how stressed you are okay
and
i'm walking to the coffee bean and [ __ ]
is just going it's a bonkers nutty good
day right your [ __ ] your boy went stupid
viral earlier on in the day right
earlier on in the day
your boy went stupid viral he probably
threw out a tick tock that got [ __ ]
one milli views a million
a million a million
that's me all day because your boy put
something on tick tock that went
dummy viral right
so i'm on [ __ ] so i'm walking into
the coffee bean with that [ __ ] head
bop i'm really i'm really i'm really i'm
i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm a middle-aged
right my dad thinks that's a song about
emily emily emily emily and um
what's that song by little perp emily um
so
so i do this i i walk in one door
which i think that this is my problem is
i walked in the door that i don't
normally walk into right i walk there's
two dog two dogs there's two doors in
the
coffee bean i went into the door that i
don't normally go into
and it kind of [ __ ] my [ __ ] up so i
walked and i went to the cash register
the lady said this isn't my normal one
with claudia this isn't my normal one
right there which she knows the ice
americano dry [ __ ] one person does in
this coffee bean but it's the person who
makes the coffee not the person at the
cash register and there's always more
people there so they start it but she's
like what would you like so i say i
would like a nice americano dry and she
says great let me bring you up take my
wallet out go to do it as i'm taking my
wallet out i look over to my left side
and i see a guy walking in the door that
i just walked into the door that i don't
normally walk into so i see him walking
in and there's a table that i want to
sit at now i see that table
and i'm worried that this guy is going
to take that table now
i don't know what the rules are here
right if i'm ordering look i was in the
place first
first of all i was in the place first so
i should i guess technically have my
choice of table before the guy that
walked in
but also if i walk straight to the
register and i'm ordering a guy walks in
he's not gonna [ __ ] be like hey sir
you were here first which table would
you like and also even thirdly
it's not that big of a deal really it
isn't okay it's just a preference i'd
like to sit at this table and it's
between me and the guy walking in
i made a decision that i'm not proud of
okay
i decided to i i don't like when people
do this [ __ ] but i wanted to put
whatever i had on me on the table
so he wouldn't take it i and i'm not i'm
honestly i don't like that i did that
and i'm not gonna do it anymore because
that's [ __ ] if the guy wants the
table i'm not gonna i don't want him to
see the table and be like oh good a
table and then all of a sudden i drop my
hoodie on and then he's like ah never
mind okay i don't want his
disappointment to be because of me and
that's on god
so
he's walking in and i made a game time
decision right
i'm not proud of but i didn't have a
hoodie i just had a shirt and pants and
shoes on and i took my wallet out and i
went to go toss my wallet on the table
now as i'm tossing my wallet on the
table i realize as it's
ejecting out of my my left hand my weak
hand all right
oh it's actually too far to throw
anything indoors
it the table is too far
nobody should be throwing anything
this far
not just indoors but even around people
and i'm throwing something too far
indoors
and
practically at a guy walking through the
door all right
so
i toss it
again it's my weak hand i threw it too
high
it hits his peak and comes just rushing
down faster than gravity but rushing
down hits the table and it goes
it was like my wallet was the size of a
graduation cap
no a laser disc no
whatever's bigger than that i'm good for
two examples that's my comedic chops
and um yeah it was like i lopped a
[ __ ] laserdisc on the f and but a big
one
it goes and everyone in the coffee shop
goes like this
it's just my wallet
to make matters worse
my wallet
bounces
and then goes off of the table so now
loud noise
basically people are thinking
but is it a ghost
because there's no evidence
and then they all
go from wherever the sound was and they
look back at me
and now i'm like [ __ ]
because
look one time when i was in a coffee
shop a guy came in and he said
um
it was a crowded coffee shop i was
sitting there a guy walked in and he
says science is everywhere and then he
turns and walks away that guy's a crazy
person i'll never forget it happened but
that's what he said all right he just
walked in and said science is everywhere
and walked away this is before
people were really even getting nuts
right this guy was like the the guy had
to jump on the [ __ ] nuttiness
right like everybody's crazy now this
was back in 2008 when people were just
figuring crazy out he walked in he says
science is everywhere and honestly he's
not wrong
so yeah it was a crazy thing to do but
maybe he was actually just a chemist
so he walks out my point is that crazy
[ __ ] happened when a crazy thing happens
in a coffee shop especially
but in a small place of business when a
crazy thing happens
everyone who is not
the craziness
becomes best friends right
so he walked in and he said science is
everywhere and walked out now i [ __ ] you
not
i [ __ ] you not there was a hot girl
there and an italian guy
the italian guy
became one of my best friends
and i had an affair with the beautiful
woman
okay
so that crazy guy disrupted that coffee
shop so much
that i had a relationship and a
relationship because of it
2008 beautiful years
so
now flash forward to a [ __ ] two days
ago i'm the craziness now i didn't walk
in and say science is everywhere or
[ __ ] when is a fire not a fire or
some crazy [ __ ] right but everyone's
looking at me and then two people are
talking about oh i don't know yeah i
think he threw some and i'm oh and real
loudly i just say oh oh yeah no i i just
i didn't mean to if i was gonna hit i'm
sorry dude right
now i'm [ __ ] scared because i got
ptsd because i think [ __ ] soon it's
gonna be like
crazy
star of undateable crystalline throws a
[ __ ] wallet at some portly guy
walking in the same door he does dahlia
responds reps for delia responds he uh
well he walked into the door he doesn't
usually walk into and then when
and then and science is everywhere
and then that guy's up hey what do you
guys think of it and then some [ __ ]
long surfer hair duders like dude oh uh
i forget but
we caught up with bernie spears there's
another there's a i saw the ninth
documentary about bernie spears
yesterday
um
and i sat down and i'm just like
sitting down and i'm like all right it's
fine nobody really got
and this is like these are the thoughts
i'm happening like everything's fine and
then all of a sudden just to make
matters
weirder
these two like
kids brothers came in with in like
karate keys and with a dad and the dad
was like just go sit over there and he
like pointed at my table and i'm just
like ah for [ __ ]
what is ha i'm sitting
and then i now i got like two karate
kids next to me
and and and they don't have masks on
which is fine i don't care about that at
all but a kid turns over to me and goes
up to and sneezes and i'm like dude i
didn't even know nine year olds [ __ ]
knew how to sneeze yet and this kid
sneezes on me with a karate key
and he sneaks and i'm like oh for [ __ ]
and i swear to god the kid says to the
dad dad i'm gonna take off my shoes and
the dad's like no you're not gonna take
off your shoes and he says yes i am and
he takes off his shoes and i'm all right
you know what honestly
that's an l dude this coffee bean and
tea leaf experience it's just straight
up l
i [ __ ] took my l i took the coffee
and i walked out and i waited for my
fiancee to pick me up because my car is
in the shop sabitch
sat down took a [ __ ] made up did a uh
uh
um
an instagram post about it
where i just sat on the i have my life
rips um
on but you know what's uh yeah oh dude
[ __ ] speaking of instagram i posted
this thing about how
bone tugs and harmony i talk [ __ ] about
i guess i talked [ __ ] about bon tok i
mean i'm joking obviously uh bone talks
and harmony on by some episode it was
like episode some episode i don't know
previously on congratulations first of
all worst name of a rap group ever bone
thugs and harmony and i was talking
about bump dogs and harmony and um they
wrote an article about it
about cr crystallia this is rap group
bone thugs and harmony
and it was so funny dude like this this
woman who wrote the article was like
yeah chris
chris um
you know
crystalia was talking [ __ ] about busy
bone but you know i i would he came into
the i don't know if you heard the
episode but he came into the meanwhile
as a patio comedy store i was talking my
brother and he was like part of my
[ __ ] interruption he said it 19
times and i was talking about how silly
it was and then the late and then the
lady wrote the later darker was like oh
yeah crystalia made fun or or talked
[ __ ] to about
busy bone and
when he has a notoriously horrible
uh childhood and it's like
don't like yo first of all it's comedy
second of all i'm the [ __ ] because i
don't know every [ __ ] waking fact
about one of the bone thugs and
harmonies
i like i gotta know about the [ __ ]
everyone's childhood before i joke the
[ __ ] if i know one time this was years
ago but i made fun of somebody on
instagram for doing something silly and
she wrote me and she was like not cool i
had cancer and i'm like i gotta know
everything
sorry you have that
i can't make fun of a yoga move though
crystallia star of undateable [ __ ]
took took a cancer victim to task and
somebody who had a bad childhood to task
on his latest congratulations
they're acting like [ __ ] everybody's
hitler out there dude
so [ __ ] weird dude
it's like
everybody's hitler today
that's about it i really wanted to talk
about except for the fact that demi
lovato thinks that we shouldn't call
aliens aliens we should call them et's
dude
demi lovato what are you doing
what are you doing
demi lovato i sing cool for the summer
on lip sync battle don't make me regret
it
don't make me regret it don't make me
regret my body rolls too cool for the
summer don't make me regret it
demi lovato don't make me regret it
please
can i say aliens
she's like but it's offensive to who
where are the aliens where are they
where are they and wherever they are
they don't speak english
i'm sure aliens is fine with them
we could call them [ __ ] turkey
sandwiches i'm sure it's fine
that's how they speak
that's how they speak yourself mars
attacks that's how they speak they're
gonna be mad that we're calling them
anything they don't care they don't even
care if we open our mouths they just
want to destroy the earth and take it
over that's what they want
what the [ __ ] that matter they don't
come in peace
they come to make us in pieces
what are you doing demi lovato let me
see aliens hey let them lovato come on
let me say aliens please
call them et's extraterrestrial
come on demi lovato please i'm hoping
this is an open letter to demi lovato
please let me say aliens
make me regret
don't make me regret
doing body rolls to cover the summer in
front of chrissy teigen and nella cool j
don't make me regret it
so that's that dude i got sweat
cascading dude i'll tell you what i got
sweat cascading under my new shirt was
gonna wear it out tonight can't do that
anymore it's all good it's all good my
babies
we're a cult dude we're gonna be in tall
grass in no time just keep on [ __ ]
liking that subscribe button keep on
[ __ ] hitting that like button and
keep on subscribing to that like button
dude please you gotta do it it really
helps algorithm and you know about me
man i'm all about the algorithms
make friends in the comments below there
go if you see someone that needs a
friend you say what's up man i'm from
peoria how you doing if you're ever
around the area let's go get some
sausage whatever the [ __ ] it is dude
anybody from [ __ ] vancouver
you see someone talking [ __ ] they need
friends hi i'm from toronto how have you
been it seems like you're having a bad
day
make friends in the comments and scoop
up that merch at the store make friends
in the comments
the new sandstorm life rips hoodie and
we've got a new one coming for you and
boy
does it
bang dude you're going to see it you're
going to go like this
oh
that's how you're going to go
you're going to see the new merch you're
going to go like this
cause it's gonna make you emotional dude
it's gonna hurt your feelings my merch
hurts your feelings so go out there and
go get it
that's it you guys i hope you enjoyed
the episode to catch the rest of the
episode the uncut version go on over to
our patreon patreon.comcrystalia
and sign up it's only six bucks and you
can get all of the extra [ __ ] that we do
the rest of the episodes the backlog of
the episode episodes that don't exist uh
for uh the youtube watchers and uh all
the other listeners uh but you get
exclusive content there's other segments
that we do not just this congratulations
podcast and there
are watch alongs that we do that i chat
with you on with on our discord you get
access to all of that it's six six bucks
uh so go on over and check out our
patreon patreon.com
crystalia thanks guys
uh
[Music]
thank you
hold on one second hey guys